in the United States companies don't get
much bigger than Amazon worth 1.3
trillion dollars with more than a
million employees worldwide but now
Federal Regulators in the United States
say it got this big and this Rich using
unfair practices around 60 of the sales
on amazon.com come from small and
medium-sized companies but the FTC says
when they list on Amazon because of fees
and requirements for every two dollars
the seller makes one of those dollars
goes to Amazon a feed that it says
amounts to a 50 Amazon tax which is
ultimately passed along to Consumers
because of Amazon's reach the FTC says
sellers have little choice but to pay
and it says Amazon is also inflating
prices of goods because if those sellers
sell their products for Less on another
platform the allegation is Amazon
basically makes their listing disappear
on its site we are influenced Dubai only
from those that do everything that
Amazon tells them to do and pay
whatever's on whatever Amazon tells them
to pay Amazon is denying any wrongdoing
the case is expected to take years to
work its way through the courts but
experts say it could have a huge impact
on the company if they lose I think a
breakup is on the table it is one of the
things that theftc is asking for but
um there's a range of outcomes that are
possible and uh including simply barring
Amazon from the various practices that
this lawsuit is complaining about this
is all part of a promise from the Biden
Administration to take on big Tech the
FTC is also suing meta the parent
company of Facebook the justice
department is in court right now suing
Google how these cases turn out will
likely have a huge impact on people
worldwide and the way we all use
technology going forward Patty gulhane
Al Jazeera Washington
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera